these are all products Amazon showed off
during past annual Gadget release events
but unlike devices unveiled at Apple and
Samsung's events to place an order for
some of these items you have to be
invited and that's by Design Amazon
calls these day one additions so why
would Amazon make an announce exclusive
devices that may never be available to
the general public I'll tell you four
ways the company benefits from releasing
gadgets this way the first big benefit
is the company gets to gauge public
interest and figure out what consumers
actually want while day one products are
eye-catching that doesn't always mean
they'll be best sellers Amazon has cut
people discounts if they were invited to
get in early but some of these products
are still pretty expensive when they
first debut by controlling who can buy
them Amazon can test the Public's
appetite for a product before spending
Millions to mass produce it the echo
frames are an example of how this
strategy can play out the audio glasses
were a day one product that people liked
and Amazon made it more widely available
falling in love with the day one device
is risky though one day it's here and
the next day Amazon can kill it kind of
like they just did with Amazon glow day
one editions also generate a lot of Buzz
for the company they get media to cover
an event that the Press might skip if
Amazon only announced tweaked for
versions of old gadgets it's sort of why
I'm doing this video that attention can
generate more traffic on amazon.com
where the company can plug things you
can actually buy like an echo these
announcements can also get the attention
of third-party developers Amazon
recently launched a developer kit for
the Astro home robot and is working with
a handful of universities to see what
they come up with Amazon also gets to
set the standard if it's the first to
unveil a new device even if the product
doesn't take off Amazon gets to say that
it was first forever let's go back to
the echo it was initially part of a
limited release when unveiled in 2014.
before Amazon sold it more widely and in
the years it followed several other
smart speakers propped up with an
awfully familiar round design similar
features and a similar price
and getting an early clearly pays off
Amazon's Echo Remains the country's most
popular smart speaker by far the day one
event is also baked into Amazon's brand
identity which Jeff Bezos wrote about in
a letter to shareholders more than 20
years ago it is always
day one he said the company should show
an eager adoption of external trends and
be competitor focused product focused
and Technology focused so with all these
benefits why didn't Amazon highlight any
day one ideas at this year's event
there's a couple possible reasons for
this right now Amazon is facing some
high profile legal challenges as well as
a very expensive acquisition Amazon
sales have slowed from their pandemic
highs as people get outside more with
these more pressing issues analysts say
day one additions are taking a back seat
they also say the company likely wants
to focus on products that will sell in
the months ahead and less on lofty ideas
at least at the moment and we're all
filling the burn of inflation so it
makes sense for Amazon to focus more on
refreshed devices at cheaper prices than
experimental ideas costing more than a
grand to own Amazon unveils these
devices because they draw attention and
increase sales overall and let's say
Amazon probably knows most people won't
or can't afford to buy these day one
editions but I'm still waiting on my
Astro home robot so